la suite de notre page était consacrée
aux animaux après ceux qui font du
cinéma
christelle schatt piotin s'est
intéressée à ceux qui font le spectacle
et notamment les focaux solognot à
chambord et c'est là bas qu'on la
retrouve tout de suite bonsoir
christelle bonsoir j'ai un oiseau à côté
de moi qui bat des ailes donc je fais
attention au fait nous sommes dans les
écuries du maréchal de saxe ici à
chambord chambord évidemment château de
françois 1er
françois 1er qui est le héros d'un
spectacle en ce moment avec des chevaux
et des rapaces des rapaces qui sont
formés vous le disiez par le faucon
solognot s'était alors bini en indre et
loire où il était ce matin à regarder
brigitte cohue est une amoureuse des
rapaces comme son mari francis ensemble
ils ont créé en 1995 le faucon solognot
de lignes et de l'ibo dans le loiret à
aubigny en indre et loire
il avait trois oiseaux ils en ont
environ 70 c'est le quartier des
reproducteurs et 6 et des grands oiseaux
alors les reproducteurs c'est une chose
évidente il faut qu'il soit au calme et
les grands oiseaux parce que leurs vues
terrorise les oiseaux de taille plus
modeste
donc pour pour que les oiseaux de
travail qui sont dans le premier parc ne
soit pas intimider du coup on les a
séparés et ça leur permet d'être plus au
calme
quand les vaillants la balance dans
l'air de travailler chaque oiseau et
peser une fois par jour avant l'exercice
les rapaces diurnes et nocturnes travail
soit avec francis soit avec brigitte
tout particulièrement attiré par les
chouettes là il est important de garder
un lien permanent avec les oiseaux dès
leur plus jeune âge à la nurserie c'est
l'heure des la chorale
si l'univers des rapaces vous intéresse
rien ne vous empêche d'aller à l'école
et on organise des stages découverte de
la fauconnerie différentes formules
d'ailleurs on a plusieurs façons de
travailler
des stages très grand public et des
stages un petit peu plus poussé pour les
gens qui ont vraiment un projet de
passer à l'acte un jour et d'avoir leur
propre point de vue et puis on a une
activité de spectacles itinérants ou
fixe le couple a monté plusieurs
spectacles et apporte sa contribution à
d'autres c'est ainsi que francis passe
son été au château de chambord
[Musique]
et ça tombe bien je suis avec francis et
un bellâtre francis on va parler un
petit peu du spectacle en fait c'est un
spectacle qui mélange beaucoup de 2,2
d'animaux de la région parce qu'on a les
chevaux de salbris et on a donc les
rapaces du faucon solognot spectacle
régional
si je veux dire donc bien sûr la mis en
place spectacle les oiseaux moi je les
ai mis dans ce spectacle l'année
dernière donc il ya des scènes qui sont
très jolies et on a quand même mis un
certain temps de préparation a fallu
plusieurs mois avant pour préparer nos
oiseaux et préparer une chose vous
pouvez nous présenter au lime wire
bizarrement est ce que vous me présentez
votre éco équipe il est très gentil
s'appelle baïkal il est né il ya
quelques mois chez un ami pierre cadéac
qui habite fontainebleau c'est un aigle
des steppes et il est très prometteur et
me donne beaucoup de plaisir mais
j'attends beaucoup de lui donc là ce
qu'il faut préciser ce n'est pour
l'instant bay kahn n'est pas sûr le
spectacle mais il est amené à y
participer c'est ça je pense qu'il y
sera très rapidement parce que on va
commencer à l'entraîner avec le show
dans les deux jours qui viennent et
c'est un oiseau qui comprend très vite
et qui sera très très très vite dans le
spectacle bien avoir la fin du spectacle
en quoi est-ce que le rapace je le sais
rien mais je vais vous pouvez quand même
question c'est une longue histoire
d'amour avec les rapaces je crois oui je
peux refaire mon histoire parce que j'ai
commencé en 79 y assure qu'un grand
fauconnier où j'ai appris la fauconnerie
et de là je suis passé au puy du fou
après dix ans après et je suis resté
dans les rapaces dans les écritures avec
ma femme donc plein de choses j'ai fait
des choses différentes des défilés de
mode des trucs
tu es machin mais toujours avec mes
oiseaux c'est une vie de passion avec
mes oiseaux fait 70 je crois à peu près
ces salles me disait 1070 à la maison
j'ai aussi beaucoup travaillé sur la
reproduction des rapaces et j'ai à peu
près fait tout ce qui est possible de
faire et encore des idées il ya encore
des envies de faire des choses j'imagine
vous connaissant oui il ya encore des
idées j'aime bien faire des nouvelles
choses tous les 2-3 ans j'aime bien
refaire des nouvelles choses mais oui
tant que j'aurai cette passion des
oiseaux et tant que je pourrai le faire
exhaure et la santé je continuerai à
l'orge est la question qui va fâcher
mais en fait si tu me disais ce matin
qu'il ya vingt deux oiseaux en fête avec
vous est ce qu'il ya pas des scènes de
ménage pour dire je prends l oiseau je
prends l oiseau parce qu'apparemment il
ya plusieurs d'oiseaux de travail tous
ne font pas la même chose mais il y en a
qui peuvent faire les deux il n'y a
jamais de scène déménage à cause de ça
avec qui non brigitte et brigitte à ces
oiseaux à préfère les nocturnes
elle a beaucoup de petits nocturne elle
aime beaucoup ses nocturnes et puis elle
fait pas les mêmes choses que moi donc
on ne travaille pas ensemble parce qu'on
a beaucoup de mal mais par contre on
fait des choses on est un peu
complémentaire comme complémentaire
complémentaire avec ce bel oiseau qui
m'ont dit le béret n'est ce pas donc le
spectacle continue ici à chambord quant
à nous on se retrouve demain à la ferme
des oliviers à blanc s'apprête doit pas
rompre et blanc merci et christelle on
vous retrouve toujours aux côtés des
animaux demain